as you know as I mentioned Donald Trump
is not invited to speak at John McCain's
funeral obviously Obama yes George W
Bush yes this is sort of an interesting
side story to this entire thing we're
now learning about the continued
disgusting behavior by Donald Trump
towards John McCain the White House had
put together a statement praising McCain
and his life and his heroism chief of
staff John Calley press secretary Sarah
Huckabee Sanders other aides went to
trump and said let's put out this
statement let's praise his military
service and do all the stuff were
expected to do call him a hero Trump
said no no statement I'll post a tweet
instead and the statement that was
drafted up was never published a former
spokesman for Trump's legal team and
longtime Republican strategist named
Mark Corallo straight-up said quote it's
atrocious at a time like this
you would expect more of an American
president when you're talking about the
passing of a true American Hero
this is what Republicans signed up for
with Trump period just imagine if a
Democratic president had done this but
sadly this isn't even the most vile
thing Trump has said or done about
McCain remember back during believe it
was during the 2016 presidential
campaign Donald Trump said he's not a
war hero he was a war hero because he
got captured I like people who weren't
captured this is the world within which
we're operating we had another
controversy if you want to call it that
this morning as at midnight last night
the White House US flag was raised from
being at half-mast in tribute to John
McCain and immediately why why is
shouldn't it be longer and then the
defenders of Trump say you know if
you're gonna keep it longer than a day
and a half you need to have a special
decree from the president these are all
distractions but they do go towards
characterizing this base level of
discourse that we can't even expect from
the office of the presidency it's not
even Trump personally at this point it's
the office of the presidency that has
ridiculed and disrespected itself and
we've got you know it's Democrats and
Republicans and independents and peep
who aren't even political we all have to
change it and if you're sick of the
policy and you're sick of the rhetoric
and you're sick of the tongue whatever
you're sick of you've got to go out and
change it it is your responsibility and
what's going on is disgusting